why do i need to define values but as
soon as your organization is reaching
you know 50 people 70 people and above
if you don't do it you start to seek
hiccups
so we strongly recommend put a pen and
paper together and write them down what
you believe in
what is your product trying to achieve
what are your values and and
once it's being defined
it's becoming your north star
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an immediate
partnership with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm honored to be joined today
by shai greenfield the managing partner
of greenfield partners shai is an
experienced entrepreneur and investor
currently he is the managing partner of
greenfield partners a technology
investment fund focused on growth stage
technology companies he serves as senior
advisor to tpg and previously was
managing director of the new
jersey-based family office
prior to that he was vice president of
corporate development at adtech firm web
collage acquired by ansers.com the ceo
of igloo acquired by nice and vice
president of product productive alfie
chai is a former israel air force iaf
f-16 fighter pilot welcome shai
greenfield welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you it's great to be here thank
you for coming to our office thank you
for hosting me in this i wish i could
just show a 360 view here we're in the
beautiful salon area in the middle of
midtown the center of tel aviv
you're positioning yourself right in the
intersection as a bridge from the
venture side to the growth side as an
early growth fund uh with series bc and
the israel ecosystem very non-trivial
you know to be talking about this you
know 2021 the israeli ecosystem your
background as an executive in previous
companies sitting on the board of some
of the most amazing companies that i
follow very closely mixtales and big
panda and many others and i'm really
excited to just pick your brain in these
20 minutes about your understanding on
the market
coming and being a bridging gap for for
these founders tell me a little bit
about yourself before we even get to
greenfield sure um
i came to investing late in my career i
started my career actually
with the long service in the army
following that i moved to the us and
was doing pretty much what our ceo is
doing right now i was leading companies
in that same stage of the stage of
finding the product market fit and
taking it to market in the u.s to spend
the next 10 years once i moved to the us
first for getting education but
yeah right among among others among
others but in parallel
actually
building sales teams building marketing
move in motion building customer success
understanding all the stages
that are
after product market fit many people
miss that point and there is that
next stage which is product market sales
fit
it's actually adjusting your product so
it will sell better and you can create a
machine that is
replicable right and that's the stage i
was focusing on the next 10 years and
then i moved to the investment side and
first in a family office and then
joining my partner yuda for tpg growth
and then we
established greenfield greenfield
partners beautiful spinning out with cpg
you're still advising tpg growth right
right this is but this is different
you're understanding that something
different needs to happen in the
ecosystem here
that is between venture and between
growth
what is that something
so
as you look at the journey of a company
from round
from the seed round all the way to the
ipo
there is that step
where you got your first 10 customers
where you got
the understanding that your product work
and now you need to build a company that
can actually absorb
much more capital
and scale up right
and that stage is complicated it's
complicated because you can make so many
mistakes that will take you 18 months
back and it's hard to recover for
example and i've done those
hiring the wrong vp of sales
not only you go into a phase of
realization but then to recover from
that it's just very very costly in terms
of time i think that's a really
interesting point and i want to dwell on
this because you know i think from the
outside it can very quickly seem that
okay great yeah we reached part of
market fed we raised five 10 million
dollars now we have 40 million dollars
of capital of sometimes preempt in the
market today why is it not just flip the
switch and just do everything but more
what what is the complexity that you're
describing here people that have been
there
and are going to either get it
it's not simple first of all it's not
simple to find the right people
typically in the us that will be able to
absorb the culture of the company right
in the beginning you were three
three founders sitting together and then
hiring more people but all of you are
sitting in the same office
and suddenly you're hiring people
across the ocean
how do you
project your culture and your vision to
them
how do you get them to act in the same
way that you think is right
then following that how do you create
that efficiency that people will
actually drive the business the way you
want it's not flipping a switch
so finding the right people is one
then the second one is
what kpis do i put how do i know how
much i compensate how do i know um
what's the right goals to put for the
salespeople how do i train them how do i
create a training
program that will be and will get them
up to speed as quickly as possible
you can actually get the sales person to
be efficient
in two months three months six months
and nine months depending on what type
of organization is it uh
an enterprise sale where the average
ticket size is three hundred thousand is
it the at mid market 50 000 ticket size
are you going with 50 000 ticket size to
the enterprise are you going uh with
direct sales where you put in 3 000 and
you have lending expense all of those
issues are complicated and you need to
really think about and set the right
kpis and write mechanism in order to be
successful in that tangibly where are
you in this intersection so you've done
this yourself you know running companies
now you're investing in bnc stages
you're working with these founders who
may never have had these complexity and
these experiences maybe they built a
great product how do you actually
interact with them in the day-to-day
that may be different than if it was a
private equity or a bigger growth fund
that would come in and simply push a lot
of capital there yeah
so first of all i'm saying listen i'm
here but if you don't meet me
do whatever you want you know it's it in
a philosophy from a philosophical
perspective if the ceo is on top of
everything
and doesn't need me it's
fine
but
before we invest we try to align on the
three four most important things that
you want to accomplish in the next 12
months
and i'm asking the ceo
where do you want me to work for you
where can i take what can i take to push
forward for you
so i take one assignment on myself that
is critical for the company that can
help
the second thing if
the ceo wants we will put
a 30-40 page deck that will actually put
him
against similar companies in it or her
you know similar companies in his or her
category
and will benchmark
uh the company that we just invested in
against
the competition and will actually show
those benchmarks
in the b round the scene around the d
around and we'll say listen you're here
right now but this is where we think you
can manage to
and then the third thing is we'll work
very very closely in thinking together
who do you want to hire and how
and help interview help vet those people
both on the board level because many
times you want to hire good people on
the board that will advocate for you as
you cross to the us
and also on the executive level vp sales
cmo vp customers success etc right so
three things is the
um higher you know on the backwards
order the hiring the kpis and you know
very very important goals that you want
us to work with you and achieve now
where are we today in terms of 2021
obviously we're seeing dramatic shifts
both in the israeli texting but but
globally
where where are we in terms of the
ecosystem today that this is more
relevant now than ever yeah you know 10
years ago um
companies would hit product market fit
will reach 1 5 10 million in sales and
you know they'll get an offer and you
know many companies were happy to be
sold for right to 300 million dollars
and and the investors were happy we're
seeing more and more companies going for
the scale stage
and that's exciting because
um first of all we have talent that has
been there before
so when we invest in a company many
times we can say hey did you consider
taking this guy as your advisor
and so we have a much larger ecosystem
that can support the scale so
we we advocate and we speak a lot with
our ceos on on how do you define and why
do you want to define values and in
beginning for ceo that is so busy and
finding product market fit it sounds
ridiculous why do we need to do it you
know everybody around me everybody get
it we all been together in the army or
in another place we know each other why
do i need to define values but as soon
as the organization is reaching you know
50 people 70 people and above if you
don't do it you start to seek hiccups
so we strongly recommend put a pen and
paper together and write them down what
do you believe in
what is your product trying to achieve
what are your values and and
once it's being defined
it's becoming your north star
dilemmas are showing on a day-to-day
basis when you start scaling up and you
have a lot of people in the organization
questions are coming you can't control
everything right and here's a dilemma
and how do i react how do i vp react and
suddenly you have a north star you're
asking people look at the values
does it match our values if it matches
our values and we can do it you know
it's acceptable let's
expand if it doesn't match our values
okay
let's assess and act
it's becoming super super critical
because you want to empower yourself
with the ceo
and actually bring the people around the
world to act like they are you right uh
and that's the only way to do it and it
sounds to me that what you're describing
here one of the ways to
to empower for from a founder's
perspective others to to make decisions
and to be able to release that power
understanding that you want to bring the
best people from the different
backgrounds to handle the specific
verticals it's through those aligned
values and through being very
intentional about them
then you're able to be more comfortable
in in exerting that power right and you
know what i'm a huge believer in that
philosophy
uh across everything i do
with my kids
with the people around me i typically
like to align on the basic basic things
even on my day-to-day
and then allow people to act as freely
as they can
and let's connect again on if we have
dilemmas around what we're doing but i i
hate to micromanaging and and i think
the ceos
when they come to that stage they have
to release a little bit their
micromanagement their you know ocd
issues and we know how you have to start
but at certain point you have to grow
from it which is critical
back to greenfield where we're at right
now
a little bit about the investing
philosophy a little bit about the about
your portfolio it's not just an
intersection of between venture and
growth
what is what is really greenfield about
so we we do want to be that bridge
between venture and growth we want to
prepare the company from a governance
perspective from a go-to-market sales
fit perspective
from
the maturity to absorb the next check of
you know 50 to 100 million but
we also want to be very conscious of
where do we invest and we want to create
and invest in companies that overall
create positive change in the world
and
even though you know our
responsibility towards rlp first of all
is to make returns etc etc
we do bring that
question as part of our investment
decision
uh and esg is part of what we're
thinking about and is part of what we
consider as we move forward it doesn't
have to be each time
you know environmental change etc but
you do
look for places that are creating
and moving the society to a positive
direction
i love it so i have a few more questions
about you yep i want to take you back to
your childhood before you were an air
force pilot
uh before before you became an investor
before you were an executive
childhood what really fascinates you in
the world what really sparks your
curiosity
i was very very involved in the in a
youth movement when i was uh was young
and actually spent
majority of my time after school you
know
every day
in in activities that were
had some social change
in in social i won't say mobility but
wanted to impact society in many ways
during those years a lot of work in
volunteering
and and actually leading other people to
volunteer and taking leadership position
and it was
[Music]
a very
big difference that happened when you
actually joined the army right from that
from that activity to another that is
involved more in the army but actually
now
you know making it full circle and
finding myself again in this position
thinking again about what we're doing in
a more
in a deeper level how do we impact what
do we do how do we actually bring and
invest money in those companies what
does it create
how do those companies actually move
forward how do they impact all the
people around them the employees
and all the environment around the
company because there's much more than
just the employees of company uh so we
we spend times around that and for me
it's a full circle from the childhood
and i think that's a perfect segue where
do you find inspiration today any
whether it's in the day-to-day whether
it's a specific occurrence you know what
what inspires you to continue working so
hard after everything that you you've
done already
you know
we're lucky to be here and see the
amount of
innovation and the entrepreneurs that
we're seeing on a day-to-day basis
they come with amazing
ideas and they come with amazing ability
to execute which i don't think we had
20 you know 20 years ago
it's amazing the learning curve and how
the learning is being accumulated
around and actually coming down to
people that can execute on their on
their ideas
and that's exciting to me it's actually
very uh inspiring every day to come and
listen to those ideas and see how i can
help and how can i join the story
um
together with that what i'm trying to
bring in the inspiration for myself as
well is to
how do i bring
a very
away and a peace of mind
to the hectic crazy world of a startup
how do i help the singer you feel it in
your in your energy that you that you
exert here
it's it's it's a you know a day-to-day
challenge how do you open your morning
how do you center yourself every morning
how you center yourself before each
decision yeah how do you understand
with all the noise around you
what's the logical way to act
what's the way to act that it's actually
respecting
everyone around you for the ceo it's the
employees the shareholders the customers
for us as investors it's the same thing
and for us as human beings you know
every decision we make how do we respect
right our families and the people around
me and the people around that are you
know helping us to do what we do and and
how do you do it in a very very centric
way and that's my that's my small
inspiration it's how to actually project
that
to the people that i work with and to
the ceos and to the other board members
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself
um
you know we spoke about work uh
in most of our discussion but i think my
first word is is is evolving around
family
uh because i at the end of the day
um
i have you know big part of my brain
thinking right now and what is my son
doing and where are they and my wife and
and and the and the dog and the cat so
you know family man is probably one
and the other two awards are probably um
leader
and team player
because uh and and maybe team player
more than a leader and and maybe
leadership through team
because many many in many places i'm
trying to actually
bring and help people find the right way
to go without being
too visible in the leadership is asked
the right you know my leadership many
times comes through asking the right
questions
rather than
and that's everywhere even in greenfield
or elsewhere it's asking the right
questions and allowing people to
actually take themselves to where they
want to go shy
thank you very very much this is
wonderful it's inspiring and it's making
a huge impact on the israeli ecosystem
and i can't wait to see where it goes
thank you
[Music]
you